hey Paul Ryan has announced that he will
Knox not seek reelection because you
can't fire me I quit
I'm going to be a dentist that's really
you can't I'm quitting really no no
you're fired
good popular so no surprise but we go
now to our not in the field political
analyst Owen Benjamin boys never trust a
man with two first names Thank You Owen
that brings us to our well that brings
us to this week's seven plus one seven
plus one reason 7 plus says there's one
the chamber occasion in 1911 I don't
know Walter doesn't make 1911 like why
are you talking about that's not our
that's our capacity violation it's seven
plus one reasons Paul Ryan is so
unlikable I guess not so much reasons
but justifications number seven Paul
Ryan is so unlikable Walmart greeters
don't greet him number 6 Paul Ryan is so
unlikable Russians don't even hack his
election saw man and yet each will work
itself out ok we try find out the
cookies number 5 Paul Ryan so unlikable
a Cambridge analytical search turned up
nothing more than favorite band nature
sounds so that's what people it's not a
lot of useful data soothing before Paul
Ryan so unlikable planet fitness kicked
him out just for being a [ __ ] so and I
think I think there's a lawsuit going on
from p90x just because he mentioned that
he did it yeah
never sweetie Paul Ryan so unlikable his
wife won't even retweet him yeah that's
kind of tough that being said my wife
doesn't retweet me either but she's so
busy doing productive things and being
pretty number two Paul Ryan is so
unlikable mr. Rodgers told him he wasn't
special can you say I'm a dick and
everyone Paul Ryan is so unlikable when
he tried to sign up for the cratenbarrel
mailing list they said
we'd rather not and the plus 1 also
jehovah's witnesses skipped his house
that's this week 7 plus 1 yo forgot
finanza turn back hey did you like this
video of course you did
let's there's something wrong with you
in which case you can comment below
what's your problem with this video we
want to hear from you and we promise you
100% I give you my word as my bond will
answer every single negative comment for
those who are normal you can leave a
thumbs up and subscribe